do you uh i ask the same question to
every comic that comes on do you get
concerned i said you said you love stand
up and i used to love stand up do you
not get concerned that people are uh too
uh
critical of what might be said and what
is done or how
i you know
i see people filming the stuff it
i don't know why it bothers me so much
i'm like hey well i do know why because
i know it's a you want to be vulnerable
you want to say whatever you want to say
and then who knows how it will come out
sometimes that's the beauty
actually of what we do
um
i i don't
i haven't gone too deep into anything
where i'm worried about
something being posted whatever but uh
it does annoy me to see people trying to
record and well that's what chappelle
puts him in uh he has those lock cases
it's until the people who who want to do
that is it's like uh
it's
singing in the shower
and all of a sudden somebody just rips
the
curtain
open and then as filming you you know
you're going to cover up so it's like i
see i'm having fun being losing i see
somebody
it's like do you talk to them do you do
you stop in the middle and go put that
down or stop recording i do i do stop a
lot especially as the
and i was just in bahamas and i was
telling people to stop recording then by
the time somebody knew would come in i
was like tell them the rules and then it
would you have other people stopping
people from recording so it'd be cool
like that but uh yeah i'll tell them and
then you know uh but you know you can't
really control that but
so the ones you don't see okay and that
fear doesn't overtake the joy of being
worried about context
no no because i'm
getting more used to it now
used to what you used to you know have
you had any any um
run-ins as far as
any
has there been somebody that has posted
backlash any backlash on anything you've
ever said on stage
now when you're writing do you consider
that stuff
when you're writing for your comedy do
you have to consider that stuff like how
will this be taken whereas when you
first started i'm i'd imagine it was a
lot different when you were writing
no
it's uh
it's it's uh it's
i don't i don't have those you know i
don't have thoughts of that that
that are too conflicting or too uh
controversial i guess i mean there are
some but then i probably wouldn't do
those yeah but but you might have done
those
five years ago
that was time
you would you've never done anything
really controversial
how do you make it sound so
not cool no but
no no but you know i do music and no i
know like music and a lot of sex jokes
and right but i'm talking about that
even the fact that you do sex jokes and
things like that you don't think that we
live in a different time now than when
you started in 94 or 97. you know i was
kind of uh
worried once that whole uh
me too started because you know my whole
thing has been take your pennies off
right but there's also a movement for
taking panties off it's it's more of a
it's not our empowerment it's not having
to do with actually taking the past it's
the moment where
you like let's say you're kissing her
belly and then she lifts up her
stomach so you can take the pants off
it's that moment of of going wait wait
wait wait
let's say you like you know because you
know when you get that consent moment
she's like yeah take me and so that's
when i say check your pants off it's
like hey you got a job interview take
your panties off go get it go uh get
that audition or whatever so it's really
about that but it comes out
very like oh he's talking about that
i didn't take it that way i didn't take
it she lifted her stomach
she knows how a woman lifts her body up
oh you
you know he's alright
wowie
why are you laughing jackie
uncomfortable this whole podcast i've
been so i think like 80 in this podcast
i've been uncomfortable why
[Music]
you